[Music]
pyramids are one of the most common of
all human architectural forms and one of
the most stable but the reason for
building a pyramid is also related to a
set of religious and funerary beliefs
that the Egyptian espoused some of these
beliefs are intimately connected to the
Egyptians on landscape until very
recently the Nile waters would annually
flood and receipt living behind deposits
of fertile silt creating a visual effect
that associated floods and mounds of
Earth to the regeneration and conception
of life the pyramidal form represents
quite well the visual idea of the
primeval mound of creation emerging from
the Fertile floods in fact some early
Egyptian temples kept a miniature
primeval mound which could take the form
of a pyramid carved from a block of
stone called benben this was a
representation of the first mound of
land which appeared after the waters of
creation receded from this primeval
mound and according to the Egyptian view
the Sun rose for the first time giving
life and warmth to the newly created
earth representations of the been been
incorporated the very power of life
itself
as such monuments had not only aesthetic
value but were also imbued with powerful
religious symbolism the primeval mound
or Ben Ben was sometimes included within
the tomb structure and in this context
they were believed to provide the power
necessary for the spiritual rebirth of
the tomb owner the rectangular mud-brick
structure known as mastaba seems to have
been connected to the representation of
the primeval mound pyramids are
therefore representations of the benben
mound but on a monumental scale
Ben Ben was also the name given to the
pyramidion or the tip of a pyramid or
obelisk both de ben ben and the pyramids
symbolized the Rays of the Sun according
to the Pyramid Texts which were
nevertheless found engraved in later
pyramids the king would mount up to the
sky by using the sun rays as a ramp
thus the pyramid was also a place of
cycle and spiritual transformation which
allowed the king to ascend to heaven and
join the solar God during his daily
rebirth it is worth noting that the
original appearance of the Pyramids at
Giza was very different from today since
at least the pyramids of Khufu and
Khafre would have been encased in
shining white limestone which would have
reflected the sun's rays and created a
splendid visual effect in addition the
pyramid complex also served as a model
of the Arkell structure of the Egyptian
culture with the Kings pyramid towering
over all other structures and surrounded
most closely by his most important
officials this means that the
significance of such cemeteries is not
only religious or funerary but it also
reflects the practices of an entire
society
you